[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات الاستعراض الاعلامي الاسرائيلي
وصديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور مساء
الخير معال الدكتور اهلا سيد ب صديقي
العزيز الاصدقاء بيسالوني كتير عليك
الظروف لم تسمح ان احنا نتقابل معيد ما
مظبطتش واسبوعين كتير وبشكر كل اللي سالوا
علي الاصدقاء والجدعان والحلوين ربنا
يخليك مع الدكتور عاوز استاذنك ان يكون
السؤال الاول بمناسبه انه مر اكثر من 100
يوم ان احنا نستعرض كده حصاد ال 100 يوم
من وجهه نظر الاسرائيليين دعوا خطا تحت من
وجهه نظر الاسرائيليين شايفين 100 يوم
اللي فاتت
ازاي يعني بعد تحيه مجددا لحضرتك
والمشاهدين بالفعل هناك محطه مهمه كبيره و
هيي محطه ال 100 يوم فبيحصل مراجعه حصاد
الجانب الاسرائيلي بيدور على الانجازات
بيدور على الثمن اللي دفع في ال 100 يوم
بيدور ليه استمرت 100 يوم يعني احنا
المفترض داخلين نغير خريطه الشرق الاوسط
حسب نتنياهو ما كان بيوع فدخل غزه ما خرجش
يعني هو الفكره ان المرحله دي بتاعه البري
بتنتهي بدون انجازات انا شايف طبعا الجانب
الاسرائيلي بيقول ان احنا قتلنا 9000 من
كوادر حماس طب دول يعني اولا ما فيش اثبات
وانا بشكك في مصداقيه الارقام الاسرائيليه
بشكل عام ف ما ينفعش ان احنا نمشي ورام
عمياني كده وسوابق كلها يعني مخزيه فهو
بيقول انا قتلت 9000 طيب انت دلوقتي دخلت
شمال غزه بدات بشمال غزه هل سيطرت عليه
فما فيش رشاقات صاروخيه منها الرشقات
الصاروخيه بتطلع من شمال غزه وجنوب غزه من
الاماكن المتواجد فيها قوات الاحتلال هل
انت افرجت عن واحد من المحتجزين والاسر ما
طلعش واحد الانجاز مثلا اللي بندور عليه
ان هو الصف الاول من قيادات حماس هل تم
اصطياد حد منهم لا ما اصطدت طيب بالنسبه
لصالح العاروري هو سياسي وخارج غزه مش
لاقيين جاز لدرك ان هم بينزلوا لتحت جدا
يقول لك ايه لقينا فاتوره مكتوب عليها
اسماعيل هنيه ان هو بيشتري ذب لقينا رخصه
جوه عربيه واحد من المقاومين سايبها
وبعدين هنستفيد من الرخصه احنا دخلنا
نستدل على عنوانه مثلا بقت مسخره لان انا
رايح على بيت السنوار يعني هو هيستناك في
البيت ما هو والكاريكاتير سخر وبقت مشكله
كبيره فهو يعني اكتشف بيت السنوار يعني
بيت السنوار بالسر بال السر هو مش هيستناك
ده هو اخلى القواعد يعني انا اللي بدا يوم
7 فاي مخزون للسلاح علني اي معسكرات اي
قوات امن عارف انها بقت اهداف فيوم 7عه
الساعه 6 ونص كانت فاضيه الجانب الفلسطيني
بعد ما خلاص العمليه طلعت اول حاجه
بيعملها ان هو بيخلي الاماكن اللي سيتم
استهدافها اللي هو بنك الاهداف الجانب
الخساير بقى الاحتياط ده الانجازات انا
بضور على انجاز ان مثلا ايه نتنياهو دخل
غزه اه الصور مش واضح ان هو داخل غزه بس
ما علينا انت بتشكك في ده اه في 50 ثانيه
مثلا قاعد في مكان مغلق والفيديو كله
دقيقه
وثانيتين يعني ما علينا الانجاز اللي بدور
عليه رئيس الاركان دخل رئيس الاركان طبعا
في البدايه كان مرهق جدا ويبدو عليه
الانهاء و دخل اكثر من مره ولا هي اه انا
قصدي ان هو نفسه كان ظهوره نفسه مدعاه قلق
للجانب الاسرائيلي يعني هو ده رئيس
الاركان بحالته دي هيقدر ياخدنا
البدايه بتاعه 10 ايام انا قعدت 10 ايام
عشان اطلع العناصر المقاومه اللي دخلت جوه
ارض اسرائيل جوه حدود من 8 اكتوبر من 7
اكتوبر لغايه 17 علشان اطلع العناصر اللي
هجمت اللي هي ما يسمى بغلاف غزه اه بالضبط
فانا دلوقتي عشان كمان اخلص عليهم انا
ضربت الناس بتوعي اه وبيعت دبابات ومرايات
ضربت الجميع قعد 10 ايام الطريقه دي طيب
بالنسبه لاعداد القتله يوم 7 قال 1400
اسرائيلي اسرائيلي بعد كده قالوا 1200
قالوا الفرق ده فين لو سمحت بعد اذنك
فهمني في 200 كده تشرح لنا لو سمحت قال لك
اه كنا فاكرينهم اسالين طلعوا مقاومين
يعني انت بعد ما عملت العمليه والجثث
قدامك والواقعه انتهت مش قدر تميز مين
اللي معاك ومين اللي ضدك انما من السماء
انت عارف ان ده ضدك وده معاك فهو
المسؤوليه عن مقطل 1200 دي يعني جزء كبير
منها بنيران اسرائيليه جزء كبير فدي الفشل
الامني طب
الاقتصادي احنا دلوقتي الضرايب
زادت التضخم زات حتى يعني راوز دي دي شركه
اغذيه مهمه في اسرائيل اساسيه زودت
الاسعار 255% ومشيت الناس مشيت العماله
150 طب قانونيا انت سحبت هنا على محكمه
العدل الدوليه بقينا متهمين قاعدين على
الدكه فدي مش انا اللي بقول يعني واحد زي
ريف اوبنهايمر دوت قيادي يساري سياسي
يساري معروف وليه برامج اعلاميه قال
الكلام ده قال ان احنا يا جماعه في نقاط
محدده خسرانين انا استاذنك انت بعتت لي
كلامه اريف اوبنهايمر وده سياسي واعلامي
واظن ان هو من حركه السلام هناك مش كده
برض اه من مؤسسه حركه السلام الان ومن
اصغر الناس كان 15 سنه من شباب او فتيان
المجموعه دي وهو من اصول متطرفه يعني هو
قلب على اسرته على قلب على اسرته هو قال
تويته ولكن معبره جدا قال فشلنا في غزه ده
محصله ال 100 يوم فشلنا في غزه واصبحنا
الان على دكه المتهمين في محكمه
لاهاي الاسر بيتكلم على اسراهم يعني
الاسرائيليين لم يعودوا قادت ماس لم يتم
المساس بهم تم اجلاء مئات الالاف من
الاسرائيليين من منازلهم تكاليف باهضه على
الاقتصاد العجز يتزايد الضرائب ترتفع
فتقريبا اللي انت قلته هو لخصه في تويتر
اه هو الفكره الاساسيه ان ايه بيقولوا لهم
يعني احنا ما اتفقناش على كده احنا جايين
من اخر الدنيا جايين من دول العالم عشان
ارض تفيض عسلا ولبنا انما ماموتش اه عسل
الفلسطينيين و ايض
ببلاش بما ان احنا اتكلمنا عن ا يعني
الحصاد اللي الاسرائيليين انت الحقيقه
الدكتور احمد بعت لي روابط كتيره بس اللي
قاله هو ملخص عدد كبير من الروابط سوف
اضعها لحضراتكم للمتابعه طبعا هي روابط
باللغه العبريه وانا بضع يعني ترجمه سريعه
ليها باللغه العربيه لكن من اراد ان يرجع
اليها اهلا وسهلا انما بما ان احنا
اتكلمنا ان احد اوجه
الفشل هو انه اسرائيل بقت للمره الاولى في
تاريخها امام محكمه لاحي هل ممكن تدينا
كده فكره الاول هل ده عامل قل في اسرائيل
ولا المساله بالنسبه لهم يعني مساله هينه
لا الا بدليل انها حضرت هو كان ممكن تقاطع
زي الجدار العازل جدار الفصل العنصري 2004
كان في قدام محكمه العدل الدوليه اسرائيل
قطعت الامم المتحده بعد 2014 شكلت لجنه
تحقيق مجلس حقوق الانسان وطلع تقرير
اسرائيل قطعت ما المره دي هي موقعه على
معاهده منع الاباده لانها كانت شايفه انها
مستفيده سنه 48 انها تعرضت للاحداث
النازيه تعرضت لاباده جماعيه اه فانها اول
واحد وعمرها ما هيجي الدور عليها انها في
يوم من الايام تبقى متهمه فدايما تقدم
نفسها على انها الضحيه وتبتز حتى الان
المانيا وسويسرا وعايزه تعويضات من بولندا
بولندا تقول لهم انا كنت محتله يعني انا
محتله من كله يعني انت بتاخد تع منيا ومن
روسيا بتاخد تعويض مني انا بلدي كلها
محتله وانا اللي كنت بدير البلد فدي ادي
المواضيع اللي هي بتقدم نفسها ضحيه فحاليا
طلعت انها متهمه فمثلت امام المحكمه
فاختارت قاضي اللي هو اهارون بارك كان
قاضي رئيس المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل وليه
احكام ضد اختارته ليكون ممثله داخل هي
المحكمه اللي هم 15 قاضي 15 قاضي وواحد
يمثل جنوب افريقيا اختاروا نائب رئيس
المحكمه العليا هناك وهو اسرائيل اختارت
هذا الشخص بس هو داخل على 90 يعني المحكمه
هتستمر لسنوات انا بقول ده افلاس في بنك
الشخصيات الاسرائيليه ان انت حاجه لسه
بتبتدي لمده خمس ست سنوات فجبته وجبته هو
اصلا قبلل كده كان ليه مواقف ضد الحكومات
اليمينيه لكن في نفس الوقت ضد الفلسطينيين
في قرارات عديده يعني انت بتتكلم على
اهرون براك وده شخصيه قضائيه مرموقه في
اسرائيل سنه دلوقتي حوالي 87 سنه فعلا
القضيه منتظر ان هي تستمر يعني اعوام
فطبعا يعني اه ده صحيح يعني في الغالب لما
يصدر الحكم هيكون هو في ال0 يعني
ا عن الحكم انا بس عاوز استاذنك او اذكر
الناس انه جنوب افريقيا لما جرجرت اسرائيل
لمحكمه العدل الدوليه كان ليها مطلبين
اساسيين واحد مستعجل وهو وقف اطلاق النار
لاسباب انسانيه لان ده بيؤدي الى الحاق
اباده جماعيه
بالفلسطينيين
والمطلب الثاني هو تقديم
الاسرائيليين للمحاكمه بتهمه ارتكاب اباده
جماعيه واستشهدت بعشرات التصريحات
لمسؤولين اسرائيليين اي جال الاسرائيليين
مثلوا امام المحكمه خايفين ان هم يدونوا
في هذه التهمه واستعانوا بطرفين واحد منهم
كما تقضي قواعد المحكمه ان يكون عندهم
قاضي ممثل زي جنوب افريقيا اللي هو
واختاروا اهرم براك وفي نفس الوقت يبقى
عندهم المحامين ب ايوه ايوه فهو اللي حصل
طبعا ان من ضمن التخبط ان افرجوا على جنوب
افريقيا والمرافعه بتاعتها بارعين الفريق
القانوني وكان خير ربنا كتير يعني عنده
ادله بالجمله يعني وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
قال مش هندخل الميه مش هندخل الكهربه مش
هندخل الاكل ده جريمه دي اه اباده وان
هتقول ايه على واحد بيمنع الميه فدي حاجه
الحاجه الثانيه ان يعني تصريحات نتنياهو
نفسه كتير وقبل المحكمه بيوم في واحد تطوع
وقال عضو كنيست عن الليكود قال نحرق
غزه ما تقعش شعره من جندي اسرائيل وما فيش
ابرياء هناك
فطبعا واحد عامل كريكاتير اسرائيلي ان
براك ده قاعد على المنصه بيشد في شعره
براك اه حرم براك قاعد بيشد في شعره ويقول
لك انت جاي انت جاي مع مين يعني مش
ناقصات يعني بيحط التاتش قبلها طبعا على
طول قبلها بيوم نتنو بالانجليزي احنا مش
بتع كلام من ده واحنا مش بتع ترنسفير ولا
ترحيل جماعي بالانجليزي قبلها على طول قبل
المحكمه ان هو كده بيلطف والناس مش تاخد
بالها من ان هو قال تصريحات نقلا عن
الاسفار اللي كان بتحدث عن الاباده في
بيستشهد بنصوص من التوراه بالبط يعني
تفسيرها لابد من اباده اباده دي اباده كره
و فهو الفكره بس ان الزوج اسمه ابنه هارون
براك كانت عبرت عن غضبها من ما يحدث داخل
غزه وقالت انا هضرب عن الطعام احتجاجا على
الاحداث دي كتير كده الدم بتاع
الفلسطينيين لا كده اوفر فده فده كان برض
مدعاه
للاشتباك يعني ان اليمين هيوافق على
الشخصيه دي انتوا ما لقيتوش الا ده اه ف
الاختيار نفسه كان مثار خلاف بعد
الاختيار حد في القناه 14 دي قناه متطرفه
اسرائيليه بيقول ده بجد محلل يعني المفروض
فاهم يقول الله هو قاعد ساكت قدام الحاجات
الاتهامات
فريق الجنوب افريقي يعني ش حورنا مش يقوم
يرد ده كده تاني يوم ممكن يحبسوه هو يعني
هيفضل سك كده على طول هو المفروض الضيع
ض بيتناقش جوه بقى في الجلسات اللي جوه مش
دوره ان هو يتكلم ولا حتى الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يرد كان ليوم اللي هو اليوم
الثاني فج بقى محامي خواجه في بريطاني من
مستعان ب اسرائيل وامريكي استعنت باسرائيل
محامين اه اوكي
ف فواحد فيهم بقى قال مصر هي المسؤوله عن
المنفذ و طبعا قعدوا يهاجموا جنوب افريقيا
يا سيدي ده هي الذراع القانوني لحماس
تعبير غريب جدا يعني طه غريبه يعني ما هو
دلوقتي جوتيريش طونيو جوتيريش
زراع الحماس اه امين العام للامم المتحده
وتركيا زراع الحماس وجنوب افريقيا زراع ل
حماس ومصر ده دي اخطبوط بقى حماس دي يعني
مش فاهم مشكلتهم مع مين هو مشكلتهم مع
العالم كله يعني كويس ان انت اشرت الى
فكره اتهام مصر بان هي مسؤوله
عن اعاقه دخول مساعدات انا ما استلفت نظري
في القصه دي وارد تصحح ني ان انا بغض
النظر مش انه مصر او اي دوله ثانيه ما
افهمه انا من متابعتي ان مصر مستفيده جدا
بغض النظر عن الاعتبارات الاخلاقيه
مستفيده سياسيا من دخول المساعدات
لاسباب كثيره ابسطها اذا دخلت المساعدات
يقل الضغط عن مصر من
احتمال خروج الفلسطينيين من اراضيهم الى
سيناء والامر اللي ممكن يعمل ازمه كبيره
ده بغض النظر عن اي اعتبارات اخلاقيه يعني
فهو منطقه ايه يعني في اتهام مصر بان هي
مسؤوله طبعا هو افلاس مش لاقي حاجه يقولها
مش لاقي بنود يرد بيه على النقاط المحدده
فبيقول مصر والمطلوب ان مصر تفتح المعبر
في اتجاه واحد يعني مئات الالاف من
الفلسطينيين يخرجوا يدخلوا على سينا هو ده
مفهومه عن فتح فتح المعبر يعني اه ده ده
جزء الجزء الثاني العالم كله شاف النشطاء
المصريين وما
بيهتفوا معتصمين حتى الاغاثه والج تارش
يجي يشهد يعني ما هو اتهموه لانه جه ونزل
بالطياره في العريش ومشي لغايه رفع
بالعربيه وشاف الشاحنات جاهزه والتعطيل من
الناحيه الثانيه ولما
بتتفق المقاومه على هدنه ما كانوا بيقولوا
استاذين سبعين شاحنه ومنهم 10 يروحوا شمال
غزه عايزين منهم تكون 14 وقود لا سته وقود
معناها ايه معناها الجانب الاسرائيلي
هيقصر زي ما قال وزير الدفاع قال مافيش
حاجه تخش معناها ايه ان ما فيش حاجه تخش
اللي هيخش اصفه طب مع الدكتور احنا عندنا
15 قاضي انا
معلوماتي اللي غشيتها
منك ان احنا عندنا على الاقل سته قضاه
يفترض انه بحكم جنسياتهم يكونوا متعاطفين
مع الجانب الفلسطيني يعني عندنا قاضي
مغربي وعندنا صومالي وعندنا لبناني فضلا
عنه روسي وصيني وغندي تمام جدا دول سته من
تسعه تمام هل نقدر نقول كده ان السته دول
ممكن يكونوا بنسبه يعني 100% الحكم هيكون
للفلسطينيين ولا اسرائيل ممكن يكون ليها
لان للتوضيح طبعا دي مش بتبقى احكام
قضائيه ما هواش قاضي مثلا ده اعتبارات
سياسيه يعني فممكن يتدخل فيها ضغط دوله
على الدوله اللي هي انابت عنها القاضي ادي
بعد في بعد ثاني ان كان هناك في الهاي شبك
كان في مساد هم اعلنوا الجانب الاسرائيلي
طوق النجاه بتاعه ان هو يضغط على قاضي
قاضي او يبتزه فكان بحجه ان هو رايح
يامن عائلات لا عائلات الاسرى اللي برض
بيضغطوا على
ويبتز المحكمه فكان بعت شباك اللي هو
مخابرات داخليه وبعت مساد ف ومن البدايه
قالوا الموضوع سياسه الموضوع مش قانون
الموضوع سياسي فانا قاضي سومالي ماشي ما
احترمنا وكل حاجه انا كجانب اسرائيلي عاوز
اضغط عليه بفكر ازاي انا ق اشوف بقى هل
ليه شقيقه في انجلترا هل مقيم حد في
الولايات المتحده ابتدي اضغط عليه من
الزاويه دي نرغي لله الاقامه الدراسه
بتاعته كذا ابتدي افكر بالاسلوب الحقير ده
البعد التاني الدوله نفسها هو بينتمي
لدوله ايه روح اضغط على الدوله تضغط عليه
او اضغط على امريكا عشان امريكا هي اللفه
اه فهي رئيسه المحكمه دي امريكيه عندنا
شخصيه قاضي برازيلي قاضي هندي في سلوفاكيا
انما ما فيش حاجه مضمونه ان يبقى فير 100%
وما تدخلش الضغوط والابتزاز من ماما
امريكا او من جار السو نفسه وفي الغالب
يعني الدول الاخرى ما عندهاش القدره انها
تضغط على هؤلاء القضاه زي ما القدره اللي
موجوده عند الاسرائيليين اللي بيوظ فوا
مخابراتهم و دخلت طرف عايزه تخش طرف ليه
المحكمه ممكن ترفض الاردن عايزه تخش
المحكمه ممكن ترفض ليه ممكن
ترفض هي اللي لها التقدي التقدير اذا كان
لها هي مصلحه اه الدوله دي لها مصلحه ولا
لا اه ولا لا طيب احنا هننتظر ونرى
وبالمناسبه دي ان شاء الله هيكون عندنا
حلقه بنتكلم فيها على محكمه العدل الدوليه
قصتها وتكوينها وموقف جنوب افريقيا ان شاء
الله خلال هذا الاسبوع باذن الله طب معالي
الدكتور احنا عندنا
احنا لو ما غناش مصر نتنياهو كان تراجع عن
موضوع محور فيلادلفيا كان هو ماكش ايه لو
محور لو ما فيش ازعاج يعني ان احنا قبل ما
نسيب مصر هربط بالجزئين بتاعه تصريحات
نتانيا كان سبق ليه وقال نحط ايدينا على
محور فيلادلفيا اه الصح واللي هيتم ان
احنا هنحط طبعا ده مش عايز يقول هنحتل قال
يعني هو كده عمل شغل سياسه انا مش قصدي
احتلها انا هحط ايدي بس ف المهم ان هو رجع
خطوتين لورا وقال الثغرات دي هنسد بالنسبه
لمحور ديلفي عدل الاجابه حسن اجابته واضاف
كمان ان مافيش قرار حتى الان
بندرس بدائل فلما تيجي تناقشه تيجي تضغط
عليه يقوللك انا قصدي احط اجهزه مجسات
تشوف اذا كان في حفر هنا في حركه هنا انا
هنسق مع مصر تسد معايا من الناحيه الثانيه
يعني هو بيترك نفسه خط راجعه وب بدات
البوادر ان هو
يتراجع من خلال هذا التصريح طيب عظيم جدا
احنا عندنا الجنرال اسحاق بريك ده بقى
شخصيه عامه منذ 7 اكتوبر والى الان اللي
هو جنرال اسرائيلي كان سبق قبل 7 اكتوبر
كان قال
انه المقاومه قادره على احتلال كل
مستوطنات ما يسمى بغلاف غزه ولذلك اشتهر
جدا بعد 7 اكتوبر هذا الجنرال وقال ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي وانت عرف عندنا هنا
الكلام كتير انه غير مستعد وان تدريبه سيء
وان قياداته غير مؤهله فبدا يبقى في
اهتمام كبير بيه جدا بعد 7 اكتوبر وطبعا
متقاعد هذا الرجل تحدث الاسبوع الماضي
محذرا من جديد مما حذر هو طبعا اولا
مواليد 47 يعني مواليد فلسطين هو كان قائد
في الواء في لواء المدرعات
وتولى الكليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه كمدير
لها واشتغل بعد تقاعده فور تقاعده كمدير
لاداره تلقي الشكاوى من الجنود والضباط ا
دي طبعا خليته يطلع على الوضع الحقيقي
يعني ايه اللي بيحصل ومين وبيض ازاي وال
فالمهم الجيش يعني اه فقال ان الجيش من
2018 بيقول ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما عندوش
الجزيه واختيارات القض غلط ولا يمكنه
التعامل مع جابتين فبقى بالنسبه لهم فعلا
ايه قديس لدرجه ان نتنياهو قال له انت كنت
بتقول ايه بقى تعالى ممكن نجتمع مع بعض فا
ابتدى يبقى ايه يقولوا له تعال كده احنا
ما ركزنا معاك ممكن تقول ثاني ما ركز معكش
في 2018 اه فممكن في 24 بقى ايه نستفيد من
خضرتك فقال لهم بقى ده مقال مقالته
الاخيره اه مقالته الاخيره ولقاء اذاعي اه
الاثنين مع بعض حصلتهم ايه ان يا جماعه
احنا لسه ما دخلناش المخيمات احنا لمسنا
كده مع مخيم جباليه في الشمال انما لسه في
مخيمات خان يونس ورفح تحت وفي الشاطئ وفي
وفي فاحنا لو دخلنا لو حبينا نسيطر على
محور فيلاديلفيا اللي انتم متخيلين ان هو
ده الحل بدون التعاون مع مصر هيبقى فيه
خسائر بالالاف في الجانب الاسرائيلي طبعا
مايهموش غير الجانب الاسرائيلي ا يهمش
طبعا للتوضيح يعني لغير الفلسطينيين انه
لما يقول لك مخيم مثلا رفح يقصد مدينه رفح
ومخيم او اكثر جنبها خان يونس المدينه
ومخيمات وغالبا دول بيكونوا لاجئين
فلسطينيين جاؤوا من مدن اخرى مظبوط ما هم
88 اترحلوا بقى مخيمات داخل غزه 80% من
قطاع غزه مخيمات مخيمات سكان مخيمات
فلسطينيين جاوا من مدن اخرى الى مدينه غزه
او قط غزه مع النجبه مع النجبه اذا خلاصه
اللي بيقولوا اسحاق الجنرال اسحاق بريك
انه الجيش الاسرائيلي المهمه الصعبه لم
تبدا بعد لانه لم يضطر للقتال لقتال عناصر
المقاومه داخل المخيمات المقتضى بمئات
الالاف هو بيقول بالملايين بس يعني ده
يعني الجمع يعني على سبيل المبال يعني
بمئات الالاف اه يعني ا الجمع يمكن في
العبري بقى اثنين وزي الانجليزي فيش مثنى
مافيش مثنى ما فيش اثنين كرسي اثنين ك ا
اه اه زي الانجليزي يعني فالجمع اكتر من
واحد وخلاص ف هو يعني مع ذلك انه ما قلوش
في المعسكرات اللي فيها مئات الالاف بس
طبعا في بقايا مسنى عشان لو حد متخصص عبري
يقول
في بقايا
مثنى ماشي مصر نفسها على صيغه المثنى
السماء البنطلون يعني ده نعملها حلقه
لوحدها بس في ناس تحب تصطاد يقوللك في
بقايا مثنى وانت ما اشرش اه انا مش واحد
منه انا مش عارف فم هقوللك يعني انا اتمنى
ان هم يصطادو
بس طيب ده تحذير بس الكلام ده انا بالنسبه
لي استوقفت عنده استوقفت عند النسخه
المترجمه التي ارسلتها لي لانه انا شايف
انه هو بيقول قضيه قد تبدو بديه بس هي
مهمه يعني انا بعد 100 يوم بيقول ان
المهمه الصعبه لم تاتي للجيش الاسرائيلي
انت هتقل ازاي في وسط هذه المخيمات ايوه
ولا انت شايف ان ده كلام متقال من بدري لا
لا هو من البدايه ابتد يجس النبض لقى ان
في مقاومه عنيفه الجيش الاحتلال وان في
فوق ال
520 ضابط وجندي من جيش الاحتلال سقطه في
غزه فقط ده الارقام الرسميه وانا بقول ان
لا في ارقام بيتم اخفائها والتلاعب فيها
لتقليل الاعداد الحقيقيه فهو بيقول يعني
احنا دلوقتي بنطلع قوات خارج التجمعات
السكنيه بكتفي بعمليات نوعيه وابتدت
الالويه تنسحب بعد كده في فرقه انسحبت
كامله ف الاجواء ان بلينكن بيضغط ويقول
للوقت عايزينكم تخرجوا تخشوا على المرحله
ج المرحله الثالثه يا جماعه فهو ا اولا ا
كده انا واضح مرحله ج دي اللي هي عمليات
عسكريه يعني انتقائيه انتقائيه وعمليات
نوعيه استهداف شخصيات او مبنى معين فهو
بيضغط بلينكن في هذا السياق ان بسرعه خشوا
على المرحله دي والحقيقه متحدث باسم جيش
الاحتلال بطل اللقاء اليومي بتاعه ده برده
مؤشر يعني الجانب الصدي خلاص تعود يطلع
لهم باخبار وحشه اخبار كذا ا يعني جزء من
حياتهم حاله الطقس ايه والراجل المتحدث
قال ايه فهو ما بقاش يومي يبقى اذا كان في
حاجه هيبتدي يقول فيبت ده برض مؤشر ان هو
بيسحب براجع
بينهي العمليه دي او الهجوم البي هم
مصممين بسمو يسموها مناوره المناوره
البريه ده برده خط رجعه عشان ما بعملش
هجوم بري يا جماعه اذا فشل دي كانت مناوره
مؤقته بسيطه تحركات طول الوقت فانا بعيد
انتشار القوات فهو حاليه
بيجمع القوات لكي يسحبها بيحاول يقلل
الخسائر بقدر الامكان بعدم الاشتباك الا
للضروره انما القذف الجوي اسهل حاجه
يعملها انا من متابعتي كده على مدار سنوات
طويله الاسرائيليين طبعا عندهم
واصدقائهم وحلفائهم عندهم مهارات وعندهم
قدرات ولكن فشلهم من 7 اكتوبر الى الان ده
راي الموضوعي والله ماعرفش بتشاركني فيه
ولا لا واحد الفشل اثنين
جرائمهم الكبيره اللي حبوا يتجاوزوا بها
الفاشل اكبر بكثير جدا من ان هم يقدروا
يغطوها بمهاراتهم وباعهم فشل كبير جدا
الجرائم كبيره جدا ولذلك جنوب افريقيا
احسنت جدا ان هي ضبطتهم في اسوا وضع ممكن
اصعب جدا جدا التملص من التملص من هذه
الكرا لا لا يمكن التنصل يعني اولا انا
بحارب مستشفيات فايه البطوله في كده اه
بحارب جامعه داخل احتل جامعه يعني لو
عليها واحد امن اداري ايه اللي الصعوبه ان
انا ده ممكن يكون معه عصايا مثلا ا
فبالتالي ما فيش انجاز بيتم ومش في حاجه
اسمها توسيع دايره الاشتباه ده اي حاجه
بتتحرك بضرب اي مبنى مالوش حصانه لذلك انا
بضرب الاسرائيليين هو في ابشع من كده ان
انا يعني ما عنديش الراجل رافع رايه بيضا
بيتضرب ده اللي هي في منتصف ديسمبر اللي
فات 15 ديسمبر ضرب الثلاثه من منهم واحد
دخل مبنى وفل لاثه اسرائيليين ثلاثه
اسرائيليين وقالوا هيلب اس او اس انقذونا
انقذوا
ارواحنا اه وفي ثلاثه مخطوفين هنا بالعبري
مافيش فايده ضربوا عليهم النار وهم قالعين
الجزء العلوي من اجسادهم ان انا معيش حاجه
انا راجل مستسلم ف اضربوا فده يدل على
الهستيريا على ان انا بعمل مسح واباده
عشان انجز بسرعه يعني ورعش ان انا اقتل
اطفال بمناسبه اللي انت قلته والد احد
هؤلاء الجنود اللي كان قتل في غزه
واتكلمنا عليه قبل كده اجرى انترفيو انت
بعت لي رابطه بيقول هذا لا يمكن ان يكون
خطا بل اعدام انتم اعدمت ابنائنا مش قتل
خطا مش كده صحيح صحيح هو دخل في معركه
قانونيه مع جيش الاحتلال الر هذا الرجل
قال يا جماعه انا عاوز ابني يبقى من شهداء
الجيش الاس اسرايلي هو جندي احتياط وطلع
له الامر رقم مانيه ده استدعى اه فجال له
الاستدعي المفروض كان يروح تاني يوم بس
اتقتل في اليوم ده على غلاف غزه اه ف
الجيش الاسرائيلي بيقول له انت عاوز ايه
الفلوس اللي هتاخدها هي هي بتاعه الايه
المسمى اللي انت عايزه اه بس انت هتعمل
لنا مشاكل مع ناس حالات ثانيه كتير شبيهه
هو حاطط دماغه ان انا ما قلتش الراجل ده
بس ده انا قتلت 200 يوم سبعه وهيطلع لي ان
انا قتلت اني يوم 7 بالليل ويوم 8 الصبح
200 كمان قتل اسرائيليين كتير جيش
الاحتلال فبيقول له ما تضغطش عليا ومش
هنديلك اللقب ده الامتيازات الماديه اوكي
نديه لك بس ما ندي لكش لقب ان انت قتلت
رسميا على ايد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان انت
شهيد الجيش الاسرائيلي قتلت في معارك
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو بيسموه شهيد اه ماشي
اوكي يسموه زي ما هو عاوز بس لما هو مش
هيسموك شهيد اللي هو معناه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتله عاز يخليه اتقتل وخلاص
يعني في اه اه بالضبط زي واحد سيق عربيه
بسرعه خبط واحد غير قص فهو بيقول لهم
الوقعه دي بالذات هيهربوا منها ازاي
دلوقتي خلاص الجيش اعترف ان هو قتلهم ف
هيهربوا منها ازاي دي لا لا هو عينه على
المشكله الاكبر ان في حالات كتيره مشابهه
وبرضو ثابته الله لا يوفقهم طيب بعيدا
بعيدا عن بعيدا عن تحذيرات الجنرال اسحاق
بريك من ان جبهه الجنوب اللي هي غزه بالغه
الصعوبه وبيقول ان الجد لم يبدا بعد وده
بالنسبه لي انا كان شيء مفاجئ بعد 100 يوم
لكن احنا هنا كمان
عندنا الجنرال ايال حولته انا نطقت اسمه
صح اي تمام ده كان رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي السابق كاتب هو في احدى الصحف
الاسرائيليه هعرض رابتها بيقول احنا عندنا
مشكله تانيه الشمال لو فتحت الجبهه تقديره
للخسائر لن تقل عن 15000 جندي
اسرائيلي هو طبعا اتكلم مع موقع امريكي
والصحيفه الاسرائيليه مع بلومبيرج اه
فنقلت الصحيفه الاسرائيليه عن الموقع وهو
كان مستشار امني ورئيس المجلس الامن
القومي في عهد نفتالي بينت وورثه يائير
لابيد اللي هو حاليا ز النهار 22 يعني اه
اول ما نتنو جه طبعا مشي قدم استقالته
ومشي فدي الخلفيه اللي نفهم بيه هو يعني
بيميل ازاي هو حصل على الدكتوراه فهو
بيقول احنا يا جماعه في حرب لبنان الثانيه
ما تفتكروش هنبقى زي حرب اللبنان اتنا من
اللبنانيين 1200 عندنا
130 جندي حاجه تقريبا كده اه قطيل الحاجات
دي نسوها بقى احنا بكلم على 15000 عندنا
فده يدل على ان فعلا الجبهه دي لو اتفتحت
المشكله بقى ان العقليه الاسرائيليه ان
احنا هنخلص غزه نطلع الضفه نطلع من الضفه
على لبنان نطلع من لبنان على سوريا طب
حسابنا مع العراق واليمن هنسيبهم ما
يصحش فانا بقول اكتر واحد راح في هذه
المعركه حنوتي جيش الاحتلال اه حنوتي جيش
الاحتلال اه يعني ده راجل الساعه 6 الصبح
دايما نلاقي فيه وارد غزه اه ووارد حزب
الله ووارد كذا بمناسبه للخسائر
الاسرائيليه كان في بعض الاخبار بتتكلم
على انه انت اشرت للقصه دي من وقت مبكر
يعني على الاقل من شهرين ولا حاجه بتقول
ان الاسرائيليين بيتلعب في خسائرهم بدل ما
يقول انه مثلا هو هنا الارقام الرسميه
بتقول انه 522 ق ان كل يوم بيبقى عندنا في
حدود على في يوم 15 في يوم واحد
اه هو بيقول هنا انه او الموقع ده بيقول
ان احنا شكين انه هو قال قال الاعداد انا
اللي شكيت انا انا اتحلت انت كحمد اه انا
الارقام دي مش مظبوطه ايه بقى اللي مش
مظبوط هو اولا دلوقتي بقى ايه يلعب ايه
عدد الاصابات كذا 15 24 في اليوم طب فين
القتله اللي متعودين عليهم احنا ك بنتكلم
على 15 6 7 8 دلوقتي بيحاول يقلهم شويه
يبقى واحد انين حاجات كده يركز على
الاصابات اللي ما كانش بيعلن عنها خلاص
انا اديتكم اصابات اهو ما تسالنيش على
القتله تاني القتله هي اصابات اه فهو بس
هو الاول كان بيعلن القتله ما بيعلن
الاصابات فيش اصابات عندنا الحمدله بعد
يعلن الاصابات ما فيش قتله عندنا فهو
ماعلش ضحايا الصواريخ خالص تقديرات 30 دي
من شهر وديه كده ما فيش بيان رسمي القتله
من السويك انت عارف في هلعه انا وانا باجي
عشان نخبى من الصاروخ ممكن اموت من ال
هلعه ال كعبل وتقريبا بنسبه 95% ال 30
اللي اعلن عنهم من شهر كانوا غير يهود
يعني يطلع فلبيني بدوي فلبيني تايلاندي
فانا دلوقتي وصلنا للمرحله بتاعه ال ال
الجزئيه بتاع ازاي بيخب ايهم هيديهم فين
الاعداد دي ناس ماتت ففي حوادث الطرق رغم
ان في زي شلل ان في حاله حرب فالناس ما
بتتحركش بتسافر للشديد الاقوي ما فيش شغل
واسرائيل كلها تقلص يعني الشمال نزل اللي
تليب والجنوب طلع اللي تل ابيب فالوسط
الحركه هي اللي في الوسط ف بيقوللك حوادث
الطرق اعداد القتله ماتت طب يا سيدي ممكن
اعمال البناء انا ببص على اعمال بناء ا
النشاط ده بيزيد ولا بيقل بيقل اه طبعا ما
فيش بناء اصلا اه لان حتى معظم كانت
العماله من الفلسطينيين وتوقفت فالعدد
المفروض يقل اللي هم قتلى حوادث العمل
اثناء البناء يقل او يفضل لا زاد زاد بشكل
كبير فانا سرت على هذا المنوال لقيت ان في
فلاحين ماتوا اثناء العمل ان في مهن خدميه
ماتت اثناء العمل فده مش طبيعي انا ب شاكك
ان هم بيحطوا الاعداد بتاعه قتلى
الحقيقيين داخل هذه
الاحصائيات وفي انت بعتت لي رابط بيشير
الى ان الارقام الرسميه في دوله
اسرائيل بتقول انه في ارتفاع عدد الوفيات
الناجمه عن حوادث العمل زادت بنسبه 33%
صحيح وانه في في خلال 23 في 75 ومؤسسات
اخرى بتقول ان هم 86 واحد ماته من اعمال
بناء ونشاط اقتصادي يعني اثناء الشغل مات
برض حتى الارقام الرسميه في هذا القطاع
برض يتم التشكيك فيها من الاسرائيليين بقى
المرات مدام الاسرائيل عشان بيخافوا من
جيش الاحتلال ان في رقابه انما بالنسبه
لاعمال البناء يقول لك لا انا شاك في
الارقام دي انا عديت كويس لقيت العدد ده
قليل العدد اللي بيتقال اكتر من الحقيقه
اي العدد ايوه بالظبط في مشكله عظيم جدا
احنا كان عندنا قصه شغلت الناس كتير او
شغلت الراي العام داخل دوله الاحتلال
وخارجها طبعا وهو ما جرى في مجلس الامن
المصغر الاسبوع الماضي ايه اللي حصل يعني
بس يا ريت بايجاز عشان الناس با ايجاز ان
سلسله اهانات احنا عندنا المجلس الامن
المصغر ده نذكر الناس بيضم مين ومين اللي
حضر معاهم ما هو في وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اللي هو
ا اللي هو طبعا بنبر ده بيحضر مجلس الامن
المصغر اه ما هو مصغر غير مجلس الح
هو بتحضر ميري ريجف ميري ريجف المره دي
اللي هي مين بقى ميري ري وزيره كانت
متحدثه باسم جيش الاحتلال وكانت وزير
الثقافه قبل كده ولبست الفستان بتاع القدس
ده ف في مهرجان كان فهي كانت بكل مره تهين
رئيس الاركان وتهين وزير الدفاع وزير
الدفاع برض في واقعه من الواقعه داخل معه
مساعد من المساعدين انا لو سمحت ما تدخلش
الشخص ده ممنوع اللي هو مدير مكتبه او
مساعده يعني مساعده لقطاع كذا فهو قالي
خلاص ما فيش اجتماع انا راجع انا كمان مره
تانيه يفتشو عشان بتسجل لنا في معاك تسجيل
في كذا فهو المشكله دي اهانات متعمده
متكرره خاصه بنتنياهو من جانب مجموعه
نتنياهو خاصه وان بيتم تسريبها يعني احنا
عرفنا منين انا اهنتك وبلغت الناس ان انا
اهنتك فالمره دي الاهانه كانت ايه جه
الدور على وزير الدفاع
يتكلم بالدور فتحت مطلعه قالت عرض العرض
هيبتدي وطلعت بوب كورن السركه يبدا اه
العرض التلفزيوني بقى الشو هيبدا طلعت
فشار اللي هي الست مي راجب هي ماسكه ايه
دلوقتي مش فاكر وزيره المواصلات حاجه كده
اهما وطبعا الدكتور احمد لما بيتكلم على
مايره رجف هي كانت ماسكه وزيره رياضه اظن
في فتره من الفترات وزير ثقافه متحدثه
عسكريه سابقه الفكره ان هو بيعمل نتنياهو
10 وزارات كده طرديات ل لاصدقائه ولما
بيشير الى وقعه الفستان دي هي كانت استفزت
الناس او يعني لاقت اهتمام كبير فستان اه
في ذلو كان اه بالضبط كده اللي هو منطقه
المس الحرم القدسي طيب عظيم جدا الست دي
خرجت العميده السابقه ديت
اه فشار وعد بتا تسخر من وزير الدفاع اه
العرض هيبدا اول بقى اه فطبعا دي كانت
هناه كبيره ابتدت تحاول تلطف ان ققول مش
قصدي ما حصلش اصل انا طلعت الفشار بس ما
وزعتو على الناس كنت عاملاه بدون ملح اي
حاجه المهم انها ايه تقلل شويه من الصدمه
يعني انما كان ليها اثر كبير وجانتس اذا
كان هيخرج ويسقط الحكومه ديت فممكن بسبب
تراكمات زي دي هو كل شويه يقول مش هخرج مش
هخرج جانتس وزير الدفاع السابق اللي انضم
لاحقه اللي اصبح في وزيرا في وزاره
الطوارئ بالضبط فهو الناس بتقول هتطلع
امتى يعني يقولهم لا مش هطلع هو دي طريقه
اللي هو ايه لما يقول 20 مره مش هطلع
معناه ان هيطلع هو انضم الى مظاهرات هذا
الرجل مؤخرا واستقبل عائلات المحتاجه انضم
الى مظاهرات اللي هي عائلات الاسرى اللي
بتطالب الحكومه بعقد صفقه صح بس هو جزء من
الحكومه هو جزء من الحكومه المفروض ما
يطلبش هو من جوه لا اما يستقيل مش قادر
تستقيل وفي طبعا رئيس الاركان عين مجموعه
اللي هي لجنه تحقيق مشكله الناس اللي
بتعترض عليها وخلت الحمله المسعوره دي
تتزايد ان شاؤول مفاز ده رئيس اركان هو
رئيس هو شرقي وضد نتنياهو اه وكذلك رئيس
امان كان رئيس المخابرات الحربيه السابق
ضد نتنياهو بشكل واضح في موضوع الاصلاح
القضائي فقالت لا انت جايب لجنه عشان توجه
الاتهام للمستوى السياسي فابتدا المجموعه
المقابله اللي مع رئيس الاركان جوه المجلس
ال او من الاعلاميين ابتدت تطلع يا كمان
وطبعا اذكر حضراتكم انه وزاره الدفاع كانت
شكلت لجنه للتحقيق فيما حدث في القصور
اللي حصل في 7 اكتوبر القصه دي ولا رئيس
الاركان انا اسف ما انا بعتبر رئيس
الاركان ووزير الدفاع ده منسب سياسي اه
رئيس الاركان شك اللجنه لدراسه ما تم يوم
7 اكتوبر الامر ده اثار غضب نتنياهو لان
المساله دي بالنسبه له زي اللون الاحمر
بالنسبه ل يعني ل حلبه المصارعه لانه
الثيران يعني لانه ده معناه قد يفتح الباب
للتحقيق الان وهو ده يخشى ان يطوله
وبالتالي يدان وده كابوس بالنسبه له فبدا
الهجوم يتزايد على رئيس الاركان مش كده
برض ص وده استنفر المجموعه اللي معاه اللي
هم عسكريين سابقين عسكريين سابقين
متعاطفين ضد نتنياهو بشكل او باخر
باعتباره خلاص ورقه محروقه هي عائله
نتنياهو كلها اثارت اللغط هذا الاسبوع
يعني اولا ابنه ياير رجع تاني على
الولايات المتحده ولا عنده شغل ولا عنده
دراسه واثناء الحرب هو جندي احتياط بيصر
على العوده بالحراسه بتاعته اربعه كده
بودي جاردات فالناس تقول في ايه هناك يعني
ايه اللي يستدعي ان انت تخرج وتسيبنا في
اللي دخلتنا فيه ده اه يعني انت ايه
العاجل عندك ان انت ما انت كنت هناك انت
بقالك سنه هناك وا الشواطئ ميامي فيها ايه
يعني مش عارف فده كان ابوه قال انا ابني
عندي ابنين واحد خلاص طلب وذهب يعني
باستماره ثمانيه اللي هو الاستدعاء والابن
الثاني اللي انت بتشير اليه ده بيجمع
بيجمع اموال لصالح دوله اسرايل هو عمال
طبعا يعني موضع مثير للسخريه زي ساره
نتنياهو ساره نتنياهو بتقلد الزي بتاع
وزراء مجلس الحرب يلبسوا قميص اسود
بزراير فهي راحت لابسه قميس اسود بزراير
على نفس الهيئه وقابلت قاض الجيش في
اجتماع كده وعماله تتصور فوتو سيشن فالناس
قاللها اولا انت معطلا تاني حاجه بتشب
يعني انت خدتيه من المفروض يعملوا حاجه
تانيه ايوه اني حاجه انت ليه بتقلدي الزي
بتاع مجلس الحرب مجلس الحرب دول يعني
وزيره المخابرات مش في مجلس الحرب بن جبر
مش في مجلس الحرب انت عايزه تبقي في مجلس
الحرب انت ماحدش انتخبك جزيل الشكر معالي
الدكتور ون القاك كريما لمتابعه مزيد من
اخبار دوله الاحتلال تحي لحضرتك تحيه شكرا
جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم على خير قريبا
باذن الله